I have no choice I have to get a
six-pack probably that I have to because
I have to because phase three of the
[ __ ] silly ridiculous weight loss
challenge is doing chess boxing match
for Ludwig in Los Angeles oh yeah yeah
that's where you are Thanos you know so
I've got a I've done this chess box
match thing yeah which I'm still trying
to wrap my head around you have a round
of chest in the boxing room yes uh for
two minutes yep yeah and then and then
you've just brought away and you're like
right now let's [ __ ] go Rocky Baba
yeah and then two [ __ ] minutes beat
the [ __ ] out of each other they're back
to chest and back to chess is it it's
it's either whoever gets a KO first or
whoever gets a Checkmate first yeah I'm
right I'm gonna travel all the way to
Los Angeles and get checkmate like three
moves
[ __ ] and he's like uh
what's the castle
save my defense I can play chess
probably to an intermediate level I
don't know how I compared to you guys
who's the bet you're the best right Gump
yeah
okay okay from like public track record
yes I'm the best currently she's the
worst probably me probably Joey what
level are you well I learned how to play
from the chess tour what's your chest
I've never even touched the chessboard I
only started chess.com like a month
again what's your rating what's your
rating on that brilliant
how do you find out your rating your
numbers
you go on your profile picture and if
you've been playing chess these these
should have a number next to it but if
I've only been playing a month well it's
still yeah yeah yeah yeah even after
like one match it'll tell you the number
yeah because you start off with a number
do you know if he's been training a lot
for the boxing I don't know that though
oh what if he's been trained like a
madman yeah well let's hope not let's
hope not but I what if what if there's
just one guy who's just been putting all
of his training into like the chess I'm
not into like the boxing I've run away
yeah just run away right that's a
legitimate strategy yeah right I almost
wish it was just a pure boxing match in
some respect because he could just focus
on that one thing you have to focus on
two sort of one mentally challenging one
physically challenging I think that's
the whole point of one minute
to wonder where the event will lean more
is it more for the comical aspect of it
or is it more for the serious like
boxing sport Ludwig has instructed us to
take it very seriously yes it's not like
a joke I don't think it's just is the
what's the one yeah I don't know if it's
as mentally serious as that that was
sanctioned by the boxing like yeah well
this is sanctioned by the chess boxing
Federation
but it's you know it's still very
serious and stuff oh yeah I'm taking it
deadly seriously and I have been
training a little bit with boxing but I
need to ramp that up soon the main thing
is before you even start boxing I need
to just get fit because it just it just
takes it out of you when you're punching
and you know yeah like one Boxing class
and I my body was ruined yeah yeah and
so by doing the cycle and the Spartan
Race and a few other things I'm sort of
building up to it as well yeah
um but yeah my aim this year I got a
really bad like Health Report in the
middle of this year cholesterol very bad
and your blood levels rubbish and your
blood pressure [ __ ] it's just like
nothing nothing was good yeah the doctor
was like your kidneys my liver was like
really bad and he's like you must drink
a lot I'm like not really
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah because we were going on tour and
we're just like let's uh let's delay it
let's see if we can delay it and they
say yes uh mostly because like our
health exam was meant to be just after
we came back from America and I think we
just like we we just we didn't want to
see it to the hospital uh you're dead
but now it's instead it's when we come
back from America so yeah yeah you're
gonna your health report's gonna be an
atrocity oh yeah yeah if you fought in a
war recently right what's happened to
yourself have you been carb loading
you know I this year for some reason I
just lost a lot of motivation uh
sometime around April a few things went
wrong after right the Kim Watanabe thing
came out the documentary I was very
happy on a high yeah and then the
earthquake came and knocked down the
studio and I was like ah [ __ ] and then I
went on journey across Japan which is a
[ __ ] nightmare to shoot yeah and I
ruptured my eardrums and got heat stroke
every single day
water sports and I I came off the site
into the water like that yeah like just
blue it was amazing because we didn't I
wish I had filmed my POV of it because
it was Chris and um and real Taro on the
on the back of this boat oh no that was
nasty sorry it was it was Chris and
nasty on the back of speedboat this
thing was probably like the truth the
scent your fuel force was probably like
it's going out late so they're using
NASA to like launch people into [ __ ]
space I reckon you were going at like at
least 60 70. the problem was you know
with this competition it was one of
these things we hold on to the back of a
rubber ring yeah as it's being tugged
around yeah and uh natsuki and I were
against Jerry and ryotaro yeah we
weren't doing very well but we were like
we're gonna nail this one yeah and we
held on really long and did really well
and this guy he must have been like in
the yakis or something this was a really
shady outfit doing these water sports he
was like Max Speed 100 and he [ __ ]
took us around the corner and I I knew I
was like if I fall off like I'm gonna
get brain damage yeah it was so fun and
and I remember just the moment Chris let
go of the Ring yeah it was like he he
actually tumbled on the surface of the
wall oh my God it was like falling off a
vehicle yeah it was really bad it didn't
you know it's just like flew across the
like a skipping he just flew across the
surface I'm just like holy [ __ ] Jesus
it's like imagine getting like a
screwdriver and ramming it down your ear
just like that and then the pain was an
unimaginable and I had to like not pass
out in the water because but then we
took Chris to go see a uh in ear and eye
specialist because there was one in
ishigaki that just happened to speak
English as well we're like great let's
go to that right and I remember because
you know I was sitting in there doing
the translation thing right and uh you
know they'd put the camera inside Chris
is here and I'm just like oh my God
there is an actual [ __ ] hole there's
a hole in there it's just a straight up
hole in his eardrum I'm like
he's deaf but he's just like there's no
recovery from that oh it was really bad
I was deaf in my right ear for like a
month and a half but then the guy was
like you are okay
well you can recover from that you can
you're here it eventually recovers I was
scared about flying on the plane
right happening but it was like no
problem there's a hole in your ear so
depression goes straight through I was
like Yay the plane wasn't too bad yeah
and it was literally just like here's
some painkillers so you had the UK trip
a month later yeah and the the hole
started to heal
um I could start hearing again but the
doctor that I saw and said I was like oh
it's very you know you weren't because
your ear is still kind of sensitive it
could just explode on the flight yeah
precious sort of builds up right yeah so
that was really unpleasant so the build
up to the flight to the UK I don't like
flying yeah I was gonna say you don't
like flying anyway right
knowing half your head's gonna explode
mid-flight and there's gonna trap
everywhere like it was just like oh no
kill me and so I had this like
succession of bad things happen right
yeah and then right at the end of that
it was like here's a Health Report just
to [ __ ] kick him while you're down I
was like no my blood pressure and
everything's really bad so UK you won't
have as well yeah you just did not hold
that I did go handling every single time
I saw Chris it was like dessert a cheese
board
again oh my God that restaurant we had
two oh the blooming Christmas just like
help me please help me with this board
and we're all like no no no how much
Camembert would you like Sir with that
restaurant when you you mugged me off so
you know we're gonna go meet at this
restaurant this really fancy uh what's
the name of the chef Essen Blumenthal
well I don't give a [ __ ] but Chris loves
these restaurants
and so I get there first and I'm I'm
like messaging Chris I'm like I don't
know what's what's the resolution what's
the reservation name because I'm like
what did you put it on though is it your
name your friend's name yeah like whose
name is
so he replies with the name Barry
chopsticks
right that was sarcastic I was like what
do you thinking
literally just Barry Chopsticks via text
got nothing to go off right and so I
think this is like him [ __ ] with me
right so I message him I'm like What's
it really under he sees it ten minutes
goes by doesn't reply and I'm waiting
outside I'm like I want to [ __ ] go in
the restaurant
so I go in I go into this really it's in
the Mandarin Oriental Hotel in London
it's like this ridiculously fancy hope
this is like like the Queen's guards
outside this hotel it's ridiculous and
if you go in there and you look even
remotely poor they're like no no yeah
like they're just like so I'm going in
there and I'm like yeah I have a
restaurant reservation so they let me in
they go into this ridiculous Lobby which
looks like you know the British museum
stolen artifact yeah it was ridiculous
and then you go up here and there's
another desk and I'm like oh I have a
restaurant reservation for Barrow
chopsticks
[Laughter]
and they're like they're looking they're
looking they're looking and they go yep
go right ahead
so then I'm like oh this [ __ ]
actually put it under Berry Chopsticks
so then I'm walking into the we're
walking through this hotel which is like
just again it's like the most Immaculate
I have like five armed guards supporting
me and they all look like Butlers and
stuff and it's ridiculous I go to this
other place again I'm dressed in like
I'm sweating it was so hot in the UK
sweaty I look gross I like wearing jeans
I go to this other guy and uh we're
finally at the front of a restaurant I'm
like oh that wasn't the actual like
thing to get in the rest
they have a reception for the reception
they have a reception for the reception
okay and then this guy really like you
know fancy and uh he's like obviously
reservation name and I go once again I'm
like I'm not confident this time now
because I got through the first time
yeah it's under Barry Chopsticks
so so then he he he looks at me like
starts looking over the list and he's
like
um we don't have a reservation for Barry
Chopsticks and I'm like oh and he's like
but we do have a reservation for Chris
broad are you friends with Chris Broad
and I was like how the [ __ ] do you know
that I'm it's Chris broad is Barry
Chopsticks
generally he was like are you friends
with Chris Ward yeah I was like yes and
he's like oh very well this way and I
was like what the [ __ ] just happened and
I'm texting Chris you're an [ __ ]
you're actually an [ __ ] you're a
giant Chris and I we were traveling in
the same taxi together so the restaurant
we're just [ __ ] losing it in the bag
of this taxi
clearly the guy knows that it was Chris
Broad and must have recognized me
what if he did what if it was just like
a random guy who just said didn't have a
booking and he was just like are you
friends with Chris prawn why would you
ask that but you must have known that it
was Chris Broad and that I turned up
there was no one that had a reservation
actually called Barry chopstick
yeah so then the guy probably just
thought I was like some racist or
something
but I was like I was like what why why
would you tell me that name and then at
no point he's the message reply to me
and tell me the actual name is that what
I thought it was a Christian's trying to
be like some like he thought he was too
famous or something Paparazzi no I can't
let them know my real name
that's what I thought was going on
crystal he was too big it's sarcastic oh
so funny I'm definitely making
restaurant reservations
that's just my Alias
that's the highlight of my trip
so expensive he's so funny yeah this is
a two-star Michelin restaurant as well I
heard you went to the restaurant and
ordered from the alacar menu because the
the remember the set menu the like of
course me look [ __ ] yeah it looked awful
it sounded Dreadful it was also a bit
overpriced as well it was a two-star
mission of course it's overpriced yeah
like I was like that's again of course
Chris broad is here Five Guys it was
the menu all the mains or like a hundred
dollars and I was like oh my word they
were like 60 pounds
I don't know what it is about fancy
restaurants all the starters are always
better meat fruit though yeah I feel
like because with those fancy
restaurants they really have to like
just pack so much into like the entrees
and the appetizers because it's like a
smaller course it was like this pate
covered in like in the shape of an
orange in a mandarin
I didn't like the orange pop
the Pate was amazing yeah so and they
gave you so much and they gave you
unlimited thick bread as well and we all
got full off the bread before them
[Music]
honestly it sucks to say the bread is
better than the main the bread which
probably was yeah the bread was really
good and that's what you do with fancy
restaurants you just get fill up fill up
on the bread it was insane yeah it was
so good and then Chris got this uh
cheese board for dessert and he got it
like every single time went out of
cheese ball but this cheese ball was
ridiculous it was massive and Chris was
full and then he's just looking at us
like seven different types of cheese
it's like what's the what's the Matilda
guy called again
Brucey yeah Brucey you never tell them
what he's like shoving the chocolate
cake in his mouth
Chris just shoving the cheese in his
mouth like crying nobody want to slice
his shoes
oh my Lord what a trip that was yeah
that was so funny you're the first
person I've met who actually orders
cheese for dessert for desserts like
like cheese is just like it's uh it's
like to me ordering cheeses dessert for
desserts like ordering another main it's
like yeah it's so revealed it's so
filling by itself like sometimes I just
share is good for dessert yeah
[ __ ] bet you did